whoever takes office next in Pakistan
local provincial or national governments
will all be forced to contend with what
is described as one of if not the most
serious threats to National Security
The Fallout of climate change this time
last year Pakistan experienced one of
the worst floods in the country's
history many rural communities are still
waiting for help
hundreds of people on the outskirts of
the city of meher have been living under
open Skies for a year
all the children are sitting under the
sun when it rains we go into the tents
we don't even have electricity in this
heat our pole was broken during the
floods the longer it takes to rebuild
the more elected officials lose trust in
communities like this
the government doesn't care about poor
people they care about rich people but
for us there is nothing they've given us
nothing and they never will
Dadu District in Pakistan's Southern
Sindh Province was one of the worst
affected areas in last year's floods
this road behind me those fields the
entire area that stretches in this
direction was completely submerged many
of the homes and buildings that were
destroyed are still rubble and parts of
this District have started to flood once
again
hundreds of thousands of homes need to
be rebuilt reconstruction is underway
but the pace is slow in meher alone the
government has marked out 52 000 sites
eight organizations coordinating the
work have only received funds for 900.
people whose homes have completely
collapsed are the priority then we will
repair buildings that are partially
destroyed or damaged some of the
villagers we spoke to say local
officials are giving preferential
treatment to friends and relatives
others blame government red tape
the houses here have fallen down this
flood water is a problem but no
government officer is coming here to
find out what is happening or what we
need
but why help is so slow may not be a
concern for very long where the land had
dried water levels are rising some are
predicting more floods soon there is a
feeling of deja vu as tragic scenes
repeat themselves
before getting back on their feet flood
survivors may find themselves displaced
once again
Pakistan
foreign